we sh Aquaman with the intention of
playing this on the iMac screen it's
just this big beautiful movie you just
got to see it
theater there's nothing bigger than
Aquaman in the lost kingdom this is
movie making at its biggest movie making
at its
finest we knew that we had to dive
deeper into this world trying to find
different looks that we haven't seen
before we can see all the incredible
details of the
effect and the world that we've
created I knew from the getg goat that I
just want to keep it fully open
up so it can play big on the largest
screens we wanted to use the IMAX
approved cameras and that's exactly what
we did
hi Max just blows me
away